and then how do you think about our I
know that it's outperformed the SP since
2000 which is pretty impressive right
kind of a two-decade type you know data
set there but how does it perform differ
in the good times first the bad times
right we're kind of in this economic
crisis for liquidity crisis right now do
you guys see better or worse or maybe
just the same type of performance in
these economic downturns so we did we
did a a research study with Citigroup at
the end of 2019 of correlation so
correlation between our and other asset
classes most investors really care about
the correlation between RDSP generally
speaking orders an uncorrelated asset
class so it's close to 0 for all other
asset classes and part of the reason
these tickets do you know take a step
back and think about that is because
it's just gloom asset class which is not
country specific you can carry a
painting across borders it's really
owned by the ultra wealthy and there's
the scarcity dynamic where important
artists bodies work or constantly
declining for the reasons we talked
about before so that just that just
causes it to behave differently than
most other asset classes so the
correlation factor specifically between
RDSP is I think we conclude as 0.1 3 so
basically zero and then if you pressure
test that during different financial
crises sort of what you see is during
2000 the art market increase in value
2008-2009 it had the highest correlation
ever kbsp
which is roughly two point four point
five meaning it decline half as much as
the S&P declined interestingly in 2016
the art market declined when the S&P
increased in value our best guesses
our best guess as to why that was most
likely brexit capital controls going
into place in China and then now you
know it's too early to tell what we
think during the the current the current
Korona crisis that it will likely be it
correlated so it just it just behaves
differently